I had an idea in writing this this was
in the very first draft and it just
stayed that like someone asked someone
for a latte Pronto they were just always
yelling for a latte Pronto and then Ken
who really drives the story uh Ken Jong
overhears Ray Liotta asking someone for
a latte Pronto and assumes he's talking
to me and assumes my name is latte
Pronto and then everyone just starts
calling me latte Pronto which is
actually a really cool name which is a
decent name yeah
I believe people would go for that
excuse me Mr Pronto can I call you latte
[Music]
you and me are going to do big things
pal and respect bro
moo star's coming through
great job thanks yeah I'm excited for
people to see this man I'm very excited
what's the date again May 12th May 12th
May 12th is a day go out to the goddamn
theaters you [__] creeps
[Music]